Putin's poor showing of
the military parade
because it's normally
a massive show of Russian military might.
And today was the day,
the parade day,
and it was anything but at one point.
You could count it.
Just one tank rolled across Red Square,
a sign that Putin's war
and Ukraine
may be taking a serious toll
on the military in past years.
This parade was a very different scene,
right?
Scores of tanks on display,
all kinds of flyovers.
I mean, hypersonic missiles going by.
That's that's what it was.
And yet, despite the muted event
today, Putin
verbally was as defiant
as ever, insisting that
Russia is the one under attack
after he, of course, invaded Ukraine.
A real war is being waged
against our country again.
But we have countered
international terrorism
and will defend the people of Donbass.
And safeguard our security.
OUTFRONT
now, Ilya Ponomarev,
he's a former Russian lawmaker
who was forced into exile
after he was the only Russian lawmaker
to vote
against Putin's
annexation of Crimea in 2014.
And Ilya,
I so much appreciate your time tonight.
So when you saw the images today of that
the victory parade, right.
And then just
a bunch of
military vehicles in that one tank.
What did you think?
Moreover, this tank was 30, 34 of
the main
Soviet tank during World War Two.
So it's a little bit outdated.
They were removed
from the production in 1945
just after the war.
So yeah, basically it shows that Putin
was really scared of the drone attack
that happened from the we saw it.
He was afraid that it would be repeated
on the main line.
And that's why he forced the hostages.
He invited
several leaders of the CIA, U.S.
states, Central Asian states,
to be in next to him.
So that more was there to launch a drone.
And secondly,
the significantly downsize the parade
so it would be shortened time.
So you know,
you mentioned the drone attack.
And I know
that the last time
you were on the show,
you talked about it.
You said that it was the work
of Russian Partizans.
And, of course,
you know,
some many in the Russian opposition
and Russian partizans.
Do you believe that
their attack on the Kremlin,
what you really believe
that was
the main reason
that Putin scaled back the parade?
I think so.
At least all these discussions
we started immediately after that.
The fact
and after the attacks, firstly
the council
of the evening, a reception in
the Kremlin.
Secondly, two days
after that, the fact
they decided
to invite those leaders of Central Asia
because Putin was afraid
to show up by himself so briefly,
it was
told by the military post
office spokesperson
that Putin would appear
by video conferencing
on the on the parade.
And then
he said that it will be coming in person
but accompanied with others.
Hmm.
So another thing at the parade
the notorious arms dealer Viktor Bout.
Right.
Had been the most high profile
Russian serving time in American prison.
Right.
Was released in a prisoner swap
for Brittney Griner.
The US basketball star.
He appeared at the parade today.
And we're just looking at
video of him there today.
What did you think about that?
Ilya, what does that mean to you?
I think that they're
showcasing all the field spies,
the different notorious people
from across the world.
That Putin
is diligently collecting in Moscow.
And that's just a gesture
by the United States.
You know, we don't hear but
based on the
on the length of the parade, they do.
Hmm. All right, Ilya, I appreciate it.
Thank you so much. Good to have you back.